CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus joins us now David good morning we
heard doctor foul she talked about
little spikes that could lead to
outbreaks if we reopen too soon are we
prepared right now for for little spikes
it really depends on where you're
looking at I mean if a state opens when
they have hundreds to thousands of cases
ongoing or being diagnosed regularly
they can't contract trace them all and
there's the potential for a significant
outbreak so States really need to be on
the decline and a number they can handle
there will always be cases after opening
a state and the hope is the strategy's
laid out can actually contain those
cases so it doesn't spread like wildfire
you know the CDC report that wasn't
released had exact methods to do this
I certainly hope is the state's enact
measures similarly is is there enough
science David around it how does safely
reopen restaurants say and businesses or
do we really need national guidelines
here I certainly think national
guidelines make the most sense I mean I
think there's plenty of science the
problem is enacting that science is
different depending on who the health
commissioner is who the governor is and
not all of them have the same
understanding of the science I think
that we know what interactions are
required for the virus to spread and we
can do everything in our power to
prevent those interactions when we
design how the restaurant is designed
how the servers work design how the
chefs work we can actually put together
a plan that dramatically reduces risk
not to zero but it dramatically reduces
spread at these businesses that need to
be open and so my hope is is that we all
follow these templates and that the
templates are public and that most
states or all states actually go along
with them it would be great all right
the death toll meanwhile David is now
past 80,000 in the coronavirus dr. Fauci
said that he believes is actually likely
higher than that what exactly does he
mean well early on
obviously testing was limited and
difficult and many people were dissuade
it from going to emergency rooms if you
don't have these symptoms we want you to
stay at home was the message for
weeks and people died at home we don't
have documentation that they have kovat
19 but the likelihood is that many of
them did so when you look at the numbers
particularly in cities that had large
outbreaks New York City's and others is
that those numbers are dramatically
under estimating the numbers of deaths
so whether the number we have now is
underestimated by 10 percent 25 percent
or even 50 percent is really unknown but
I think it's clear that those numbers
are underestimated every time we talk to
a vyd we ask you about the progress of a
vaccine because obviously that's that's
the answer to all this but and dr.
foutch you said he's he's optimistic at
this point what are we seeing what's the
latest from from what you know I'm
optimistic also I mean I've been able to
see some of the data from the existing
human trials with some of these early
vaccine entrants and what we're seeing
is there are immune responses the hope
is is that well we know over the next
several weeks we're gonna know a lot
more and are these immune responses
robust enough to provide an immunity
what's going to be interesting is you
know we vaccinate populations now two
years old you get this at 3 years old
you get this at 65 you get the Pneumovax
and at 50 you get the shingles vaccine
this is going to be vaccinating people
across all age groups and so the
question is are we all going to respond
the same and it may be that certain
groups get two shots to get better
immunity other groups get one shot
that's what's happening now is we're
starting to learn about the
heterogeneity the different responses
from groups to these vaccines there's a
lot of science to go but there certainly
is data being collected that gives us
cautious optimism that we will have a
vaccine and hopefully not too far away
if if an effective vaccine is developed
David quickly do you think it should be
mandatory I think that's gonna be the
open question we need hurt immunity be
above 90% you know if everybody steps up
and is vaccinated you're not gonna need
to make it mandatory but there are many
people in the population the elderly the
cancer patients autoimmune patients kids
babies that aren't going to be able to
make a potent enough immune response so
unless we vaccinate a large percentage
of the population over 90% they are at
risk for getting the virus and
potentially having serious complications
so we all have to protect each other so
we have to find some way to get hurt
immunity higher likelihood it may be
something like a vaccine mandate we'll
see all right dr. David agus David Thank
You Gail